I'm Gary Miller and I'm a scout master with Troop 326 in Emmett, Idaho.
This edition of the Scout Master podcast is sponsored by backers like me
And now the old scout master.
So the patrol's getting set up and they're putting up tents and things like that,
and the patrol leader turns to one of the scouts and says:
look, go see the quarter master and see if he has any lanterns.
And the scout says yeah, okay.
And the patrol leader says wait, wait, wait.
If he has any tent stakes, get six.
And so a short time later the scout returns with six lanterns
And the patrol leader looks at him and says:
why did you get six lanterns?
And the scout says: well, he had tent stakes.
You got to think about that one.
Hey, this is podcast number 262..
Yeah,
Welcome back to the scout master podcast.
This is Clark Green, right into the mail bag.
Let's see.
Bernard Lawner is the troop committee chair with troop 329 in Battle Creek, Michigan,
And he says: I love the information I found on your site.
Once again, I'm starting to feel the fire of scouting burning within.
Good for you. Bernard
Harry Schneider is in Sherwood Park, Alberta, Canada, and wrote to say
thanks for putting up the article on plan do review.
We're really excited about starting to roll out our new Canadian path program in Scouts Canada.
If you're following the blog, last week I put up a post about the plan do review element
of Scouts Canada
And you definitely want to check that out.
It's a very simple, uncomplicated way to involve scouts of any age
in developing some leadership and planning skills.
Harry went on to say: coincidentally, Dean Post and I- and Dean and Harry were both
on the podcast a while back-
have national level positions with the project and are supporting the program as it rolls out.
Thanks, Harry, for getting in touch.
I really love the concept behind the Canadian path
And I don't think I've mentioned it on the podcast before,
but go check out Scouts Canada and the Canadian path
And then also Scouts Ireland has something called one program.
Really really interesting, brilliant developments in scouting in both of those programs
that are well worth taking a look at.
Paul Geets has got in touch and Paul is a new backer
And he said: I'm halfway through. so far, so good
And I love it.
My nine and a half year old daughter asked me what I was reading
And I told her and I showed her that you had signed it too
And she said that's clever.
So I asked her why the word clever?
And she said because your name is green and you signed it with a green pen.
Now I wonder how much I miss on a day to day basis.
I need to pay more attention.
It's all in the details.
Yes, if you become a backer and you get an autograph copy of one of my books,
I will sign it with a green pen.
Why exactly? why your daughter thought I that's my name.
Hey, we did a few chat sessions again this week
And once again keep an eye on our Facebook and Twitter feeds
for the times when I'll be live on ScoutmasterCGcom
having an open chat session
In addition to all of the frequent flyers that check in on the chat.
it was great to chat with Paul Napoli,
who's an assistant scoutmaster in Baltimore, Maryland,
And Ronald Moreno Alvarado, who is with Scouts Venezuela was on chat.
Timothy Smith, who's a scoutmaster in Connecticut
And John Coleman, who's an assistant scoutmaster in Collierville, Tennessee,
with Troop 56..
Stu Jackson is in Denver
And he's the newly minted scoutmaster of Troop 212..
And we heard from the 91st Sojourners Group,
which is in Kingston, New York,
And they're a Baden Powell service organization group,
And Rob with Troop 18 in Muskego, Wisconsin, checked in,
And David Scott.
So, like I said, weekday mornings usually
you'll see an announcement in the Twitter feed
or on the Facebook feed.
Come around to the live chat, check in and say hello.
Before I go any further,
I always want to take a little bit of time
to mention how we keep the blog up and running
and how we keep the podcast moving along.
It's because of the people who sign on
to be ScoutmasterCGcom backers.
I started this backer program a year or so ago.
It's based on the idea that if the resources I've created
have helped you, you can return the favor
and help me keep them freely available
to scouts all over the world by becoming a backer.
So this is how that works.
Go to ScoutmasterCGcom,
Click on the support link at the top of the page
And you can become a backer
by making a one-time voluntary kind of subscription payment
for the blog and the podcast and things like that.
And, as you heard earlier, some levels of support
will earn you a premium, like an autograph copy
in one of my books or all of the books.
But I want to take a moment to thank Alicia Jeffcoat,
Paul Geaches, Kevin Hansen and John Coleman,
who all have become backers since our last podcast
Once again go to ScoutmasterCGcom.
Become a backer this week
and I'll be sure to thank you during our next podcast.
In this week's podcast, in Scout MasterChip,
in seven minutes or less,
we're going to discuss the scale of scouting,
And then we've got a couple of quick email questions to answer
and that's going to take up the rest of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
Scout MasterChip in seven minutes or less.
Here's an interesting thought.
Scouting has a scale.
It was designed to work at a specific scale.
To understand what that scale is,
we don't have to go any further
than reading what the founder of Scouting had to say about it.
And here is a quote from Baden Powell,
from an article that he wrote for The Scouter,
which was the period article published
by the Scouts Association in Great Britain.
He wrote this in the 1920s
and let me just read it to you here,
As the camping season is now upon us.
I may say that one or two of the camps
which I have already seen
have been unfortunately on the wrong lines,
though others were very satisfactory.
I strongly advise small camps
of about a half a dozen patrols,
each patrol in a separate tent
and on a separate ground,
as suggested in Scouting for Boys.
So the Scouts do not feel themselves
to be part of a big herd
but members of independent, responsible units.
Large camps prevent Scout work
and necessitate military training,
and one which I visited the other day,
though exceedingly well carried out
as a bit of army organization,
appealed to me very little
because it was not only entirely
on military lines
but the patrols- the essence of our system-
were broken up to fit the members into the tents.
He went on to say: patrols
should be kept intact under all circumstances.
If more than six or seven patrols
are out at the same time,
they should preferably be divided
into two camps located,
say, two miles or more apart.
So Scouting has a scale
and for our purposes here
we're going to we're going to look at
two different scales
that Ben Powell pointed out
in this article:
the patrol and the herd.
Our target, the place where
everything happens in Scouting,
is the Scout and the smaller group
or his patrol.
As Scout Masters,
our most important mandate
is keeping the program
targeted at building
and supporting patrols,
because patrols are the scale of Scouting.
Herds are too big,
they're too large for Scouting
to work effectively.
The real work happens
when Scouts are working in a patrol
and they develop mutual respect
for each other
and foster cooperation
within a group of equals.
and this cooperation,
this small group, is where
the really radical ideas
like self-government
through the patrol method
take place.
A patrol is this kind of
laboratory of leadership
and personal development.
Ben Powell called it
the character school
for the individual.
Everybody in a patrol
has some kind of responsibility.
has a part in the decision-making process
and in the direction of the patrol.
The reason that we're focused on patrols
is because
those things just don't happen
when we're treating Scouts
as a big giant herd.
A Scout in a patrol
of you know
five to eight guys
doesn't get lost
like he would
in a big herd
of 30 or 40 Scouts,
where he's just another face
in the crowd.
Within the patrol,
Scouts act on this notion
of reciprocity.
Cooperation, with all its
troubles and triumphs
and difficulties,
enables each Scout
to discover more about themselves
and to integrate the concepts
of the oath and law
into their character
in a very real way.
When we have real self-government,
the Scout Oath and Law
are not just a bunch of concepts
that are preached by adults.
They're very meaningful,
They're very useful,
They become lively,
motivating concepts,
because that's the only way
you're going to be able to get
anything done
in a patrol.
You have to do it
by the Scout Oath and Law.
We want to foster
this cooperative independence
using the patrol method.
So the central importance
of that prioritizes
everything else
about Scouting.
It's the scale of Scouting.
If we're trying to work
with Scouts in a herd
of 20, 30, 40 Scouts
it's not going to be
as effective
at achieving the aims of Scouting
as it is when they are working
with a group of peers
in that group of you know
five or eight Scouts
in a patrol.
So when we're camping,
patrols should have
their own spot.
and I know that
it's a little bit of an eyebrow razor
when you read that.
Baden Powell says
if more than six or seven patrols
are out at the same time,
they should be divided into two camps
like two miles or more apart.
But he noted the difference
between the military precision
of having an even number
of tents and dividing the Scouts
up into the tents
and ignoring the patrols.
and it's a really apt illustration
of the idea
of the logistics
supplanting the idea
of why we're doing Scouting
in the first place.
It's always about patrols,
Whatever the logistics need to be
to support the patrols.
well, that's what we should be thinking about.
So every time we encounter something like this
and we talk about the patrol system
and everything,
we need to understand why.
Well, why does the patrol system work?
It's certainly much more efficient
to get 30 guys together
and run them through the same thing.
We can process them much easier that way.
Why do we have to do it
in these small groups?
It doesn't seem to be very efficient sometimes.
Well, the reason is
is because at that scale
is where Scouting
really, really works.
When we go
above that scale
or below that scale,
it's not able to work as well.
So, once again,
our target,
the place where everything happens
for the scout,
is in his patrol,
and our most important mandate
is keeping our eye on that
and building the program
targeted
of supporting the scale of Scouting
the patrol.
Write me a letter,
Send it my name,
Email, that is. folks,
and here's an answer to one of your emails.
Andy Davis is a scout master
and he sent me this question.
He says we have one patrol with 10
and another patrol with five.
We have three or four new scouts
coming into the troop
and they all want to join
the patrol with 10..
Now, how are we going to guide them
to the next group?
How are we going to guide them
How are we going to guide our young scouts
to resolve this issue?
We always want them to have the choice of patrols,
but if they all go into the patrol of 10,
this is going to cause us a problem.
So I replied to Andy and I said:
what does your patrol leaders council
think of the situation
and what ideas
have they shared with you
to resolve the problem?
And Andy replied: well,
I'm meeting with all the adult leaders
and we're going to talk about this,
get on the same page
and prepare any guidance
that the patrol leaders council might request.
We will stand back and listen
unless the patrol leaders council
makes a decision. that's going to be
really ugly or overly complex.
And my reply to Andy was:
well, you know, I understand the idea
of having adults on the same page
and everything like that.
but rather than starting with
consulting with the adults,
let's talk to the patrol leaders council first.
And that means you as the scout master,
nobody else, just you
sitting down with the patrol leaders council
and saying: here's the situation.
we got 10 guys in this patrol,
we got five guys in this patrol.
we got three or four scouts.
they all want to join the patrol with 10.
do you guys see that as being a problem?
and you know what are they going to reply:
well, no, not really, you know.
say: well, do you really want to have a patrol
with 13 guys in it?
do you think
things are going to work well at that scale?
huh,
hmm, hadn't thought about that before.
where could we find out, guys,
what size
ideally we want patrols to be?
where could we find that out?
well, I don't know, Mr Davis,
maybe we in the scout handbook?
yeah, let's take a look,
let's, let's see.
so you begin a conversation
with the patrol leaders council
where they begin to
do a couple of things.
they are going to get a better
understanding of exactly what
scouting is all about,
because you're going to get them looking
for answers
and then they're also going to go through
this wonderful process of talking and
discussing and coming up with resolutions
about how this should happen.
let's say, one of the scouts says:
oh well,
we, we can't allow them to
be in that patrol town.
we're going to put them all in the patrol of five.
and then the question becomes: well, okay,
so put yourself in the position of
one of these new scouts,
tell them that they don't have a choice of patrols,
but we're just going to assign them to a patrol.
how would you feel about that yourself?
you think that's a good idea.
and this discussion just keeps on going.
now one of the most common questions I get
are this kind of question around
the arrangement of patrols
and who picks patrols
and how to balance patrols.
and should patrols be
totally permanent, always, always, always,
or can they be a little more flexible?
do you have to have eight,
can you have five,
can you have ten?
and there's no set answer for any of this.
there are only guiding principles.
so the guiding principle is:
is that we know that in general,
eight is the target number
for an effective patrol that has
the critical mass to function properly.
but a patrol of five could function pretty well.
it all depends on the scouts. right,
and a patrol of ten could function pretty well.
it all depends on the scouts.
so you can't make a hard and fast,
absolute rule about this.
you have to deal with scouts on an individual basis
and figure out what's going to work best for them,
and that's why we have a patrol leaders council
to do exactly that.
well, shouldn't the scouts be able to choose their patrol,
or should we assign them to a patrol?
well, they should be able to choose their patrol.
that's pretty clear in every,
in every resource that I've ever seen-
is their choice. the only consideration-
well, no, I mean,
there are rules to the game, right?
we know that there's a critical mass number.
it depends on the group of scouts.
we know that going too far above that number
and we don't have a patrol anymore,
we just have a little herd of scouts.
so you know, you start talking about things.
you say: well, you know
how many guys can play basketball at the same time.
you know why is that?
why do we have a limited number?
why can't the whole team just get on the court
and start playing?
and these kind of questions are pretty interesting
in a patrol leaders council.
they start talking about these things,
they begin to understand
and they come up with a resolution.
once they've made a decision
and they put it into play,
they're going to examine what they've done,
see if that resolution works,
give it a month or so,
and if, in a month,
it looks like it's just falling to pieces,
well, it's time to sit down and talk again
and come up with another plan.
so look at all the wonderful things
that are happening in this scenario.
we're focusing on the patrol system,
we're trying to make sure it works
and we're going through a process
of development of leadership skills
and understanding
with our patrol leaders council. at the same time-
and that's the point, right,
that's why we're doing this in the first place-
you could, as an adult, just make all the decisions
and say, uh
nah, these three or four guys,
there's no way they can be in this patrol at 10.
we're not going to split up the patrol at 10,
they're going with the patrol of five,
and that's the way it's going to be,
and you know what that might work.
but you've denied yourself
and your scouts the opportunity
of working through this process,
which is what scouting is really all about.
so hopefully,
hopefully, that's not too confusing
and hopefully that helps you answer
a similar question, if you have one,
about the way patrols are made up
and who gets chosen and how it works,
go to the patrol leaders council first
and start asking questions.
that's always going to be my first advice
in situations like this,
because most of the time
they'll come up with a pretty brilliant
resolution to the whole thing.
hey, i heard from glenn grezik
who is uh, with troop and crew 709
in vista, california,
and glenn asks:
should a scout get their patch
right after passing their border review?
well, glenn, the short answer is yes
and i'll point to two things
in the guide to advancement
that inform that answer.
in section 3.0.0.3,
which is titled unit advancement responsibilities,
one of those responsibilities is-
quote: obtain the necessary badges,
certificates etc.
and arrange for timely presentation.
it's best to obtain and present these
as soon as possible after they're earned
and they can be represented
in a more formal setting.
also in the section 4.2.1.4,
the scout is recognized
is the title of that section.
when the border review
has approved his advancement,
the scout deserves recognition
as soon as possible.
this should be done at a ceremony
at the next unit meeting.
his advancement may be recognized
again later
during the formal court of honor.
so based on those two statements,
i think the answer is yes.
as soon as the border review
has completed or a merit badge
counselor signs a merit badge application,
the clock starts ticking.
we want to get whatever recognition
it is to the scout
in as few ticks as possible.
so as soon as the advancement committee
has the badges
they need to get into the hands of the
scouts.
if that's at a unit meeting,
that's fine.
a brief informal presentation there
and then you can represent it
in a more formal ceremony
at a court of honor later on.
and of course we want to do this
because scouts want to be recognized
as soon as possible for what they've done.
it encourages them to keep advancing
and you know it's just a question of fairness.
why should i have to wait for two months
to get a badge that i already earned?
once the clock starts ticking
and the scouts earn something,
we want as few ticks to go by
before he has it in his hands,
so glad. i hope that helps.
so just a couple of very quick questions. today
in the email segment of the podcast.
it's spring break.
everybody's outside doing stuff,
not sitting around their computer
asking me questions.
good for you.
but if you do have a question,
you can get in touch.
it's pretty easy to do
and you're going to find out
how to do that in just a moment.
well, thanks so much for listening
to this 260 second edition
of the scout master podcast.
to keep in touch,
go to scoutmastercgcom
and there you can read the blog
and you can subscribe to the email list
so you get every update to the blog
in your email inbox.
there are thousands of other mobile
scouts who have the scout master cg app
on their mobile devices,
which is available in google play
for the android tribe
or in the itunes app store
for the apple tribe.
and of course, there's always the vast
panorama of social media outlets.
there's 8200 folks
who like scoutmaster blog on facebook.
there's a chorus of 1200 tweeters on twitter.
there's the pultritudinous pictures
proffered publicly,
with 1900 other prolific pinners on pinterest.
you can watch us at scoutmastercg on youtube
or you can join the 400 odd folks
in the exclusive scoutmaster cg circle on google plus.
now, if you have no earthly idea
what i'm talking about
or you can't face facebook
and twitter just makes you bitter.
if you've no interest in pinterest,
you don't put the? u in youtube
and you're a minus
when it comes to google plus.
don't worry about it.
zoom into the late 90s and send me an email.
you can get in touch with me. clark green
at clark at scoutmastercgcom.
c, l, a, r, k, e at scoutmastercgcom.
i must mention that the scoutmaster blog
in the podcast,
all those craziness that we're doing here-
is not sponsored or recognized
or endorsed by anybody
except for myself.
we're not an official publication of anybody
like the Boy Scouts of America.
we're not endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America
or any other scouting organization
for that matter,
because i am assured that they have
better things to do with their time.
no, it's just me talking into a microphone
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun.
and speaking of a little bit of fun,
here's our founder, sir robert bedan. pal,
sir robert.
good luck to you and good camping.
why? thank you, sir.
until next time, everyone.